Speaker 1: The Republican Party is now overtly
a Christian nationalist party.
Now, the important word here is overtly because
they've actually been a Christian nationalist
party for a long time.
Think back, you may recall during the lead
up and during the invasion of Iraq in 2003,
then President George W Bush said that God
came to him with tears in his eyes and said,
Sir, no, I did that part.
God came to him and said, You should do this.
You should invade.
Many times we hear policy supported or opposed
by Republicans on the basis of what is in
the particular sacred text that their particular
religion follows.
All of these are elements of how these Republicans
would like to see the country run, and the
way they would like to see the country run
is with a sort of mix of government and Christianity.
Now, it's not just government and religion
generally.
It's not government and Islam, it's not government
and Judaism, although they will kowtow to
that by saying our Judeo-Christian values.
Although remember that Jews are the most behind
black folks liberal voting group in the United
States, sometimes as liberal as black folk.
So the idea of Judeo-Christian values is actually
a cover.
It's a red herring, and they've been doing
it for decades.
So the word overtly is the important word,
because now they are brazen enough to just
say it.
And we've talked before about what do we mean
by Christian nationalism?
Christian nationalism is the belief that the
United States as a country is defined by Christianity,
that the government should actively keep the
country Christian and keep Christianity at
the center of government.
Many Christian nationalists will actually
say that it would no longer be America if
it were no longer a Christian nation, and
that Christianity should have a privileged
position in the public square.
And it does, by the way, I mean, at a very
superficial level.
One, religion gets federal holidays, and that's
Christianity that that's the one out of hundreds
or thousands of religions.
That's the one.
And thus it does have a privileged place in
American society already.
They used to have to be a little bit more
subtle in their Christian nationalism, but
no more.
Here are some examples from just the last
few weeks.
Here's Donald Trump over the weekend in Tampa,
Florida, at the Turning Point USA event, talking
about Americans kneel to God.
We are Americans and we need to God.
Well, not everybody does, actually.
And some kneel to different gods or no God
at all.
Speaker 2: We will not break, we will not
yield.
We will never give in, we will never give
up.
We will never, ever, ever back down.
As long as we are confident and united the
tyrants we are fighting, do not stand a chance
because we are Americans.
And Americans kneel to God and God alone.
Speaker 1: We also looked at Marjorie Taylor.
GREENE Radical Republican Congresswoman Marjorie
Taylor GREENE saying, I'm a Christian nationalist.
That's not bad.
It's actually a good thing.
Now, if.
Speaker 3: The Republican Party becomes a
party that actually does the safe dance, the
things we say we're about, then we are going
to be a party for nationalism.
Isn't that right?
Speaker 1: Wow.
I mean, she's not wrong, right?
Like, it's true.
They talk about the importance of Christianity
in civil government and she's saying we shouldn't
just talk about it, we should act on it.
And she's accurately assessing that if they
acted on the things they said.
We're talking about a Christian nationalist
country.
But then I think there's another element.
Speaker 3: We need to have and I'm a Christian.
How many Christians do we have here?
Speaker 1: Yeah.
Speaker 3: So you see, I also call myself
a Christian nationalist.
Unidentified: And that's not a bad word.
That's actually a good thing, right?
And there's nothing wrong with.
Speaker 3: Leading with your in with your
faith, because we should lead with our faith,
because if we're doing that, then we're doing
the right thing.
It doesn't mean we're perfect.
It just means we're doing the right thing.
Speaker 1: Okay.
And then also Lauren Boebert.
I mean, it's all a very, very similar line.
Lauren Boebert at some backyard farmyard farm
speech or, you know, who who knows where.
This was saying that it is actually important
for churches to teach how to influence and
direct government.
And I believe.
Speaker 3: That great patriots all throughout
this nation and Christians will begin to position
themselves in these days and these times.
Unidentified: That pastors would have a pulpit
to speak from the pulpit of their.
Speaker 3: Churches to direct and inform the
church on how to influence the direction of
government.
Speaker 1: And then, even more overtly, she's
tired of this separation of church and state
junk.
And I know some of you have seen this clip
a couple of times now, but it's important
to include it here because it is so overt.
Speaker 3: The reason we had so many over
reaching regulations in our nation is because
the church complied.
The church is supposed to direct the government.
The government is not supposed to direct the
church.
That is not how our Founding Fathers intended
it.
And I'm tired of the separation of church
and state junk that's not in the Constitution.
It was in a stinking letter.
And it means nothing like what they say it
does.
Speaker 1: Now.
It actually is right there, and it is one
of the top line elements of the structure
of the United States.
Congress shall make no law respecting an establishment
of religion or prohibiting the free exercise
thereof.
It's right there and they love to play these
games with.
Well, it's not really what the founders meant.
And they were all religious and they were
Christian and so on and so forth.
This is one of the most dangerous movements
currently going, and unfortunately it has
more oxygen than it has in a very long time.
They openly now are touting this ideology
Christian revolt, revival, Christian nationalism,
using their religiosity to justify homophobia,
to justify transphobia, to justify sometimes
racism, to justify demeaning or putting in
positions, subservient positions, other religions,
which is certainly not what the Founding Fathers
meant.
So this is another layer you've got.
To go back a little bit.
We have like the neocon spread democracy layer
of right wing ism that's less present right
now, but it could come back at any time that
was more under like the Bush administration.
You have the sort of wacky, reactionary Trumpist
layer to this right wing movement, which is
still present and may come back full force
depending on what happens in 2022 and in 2024.
But then you have the Christian nationalist
element, which is just as dangerous, and it
is so fundamentally at odds with what the
United States is supposed to be.
So what do we do?
Well, we've got to vote.
I mean, it's I know it's at this point, it
feels almost like not enough.
And also, like, really, that's also the solution
there.
Yeah.
I mean, if these people are in power, they
can't do it.
It's that simple.
And of course, they're trying to use between
gerrymandering and election manipulation,
I guess, is what we're calling it now.
They are trying to take control even when
they don't win.
So just another reason why the 2022 midterms
are arguably the most important that I can
remember